mexico has the world's third highest
covet 19 death toll behind the united
states and brazil
over 215 000 people are known to have
died
testing is limited and experts believe
that the real death toll is actually
much higher so the government is seeking
to speed up vaccinations only around
five percent of the population is fully
inoculated and
mexico was appealing for more shots from
abroad earlier this month
president andres manuel lopez obrador
received the astrazeneca
shot but mexico is also developing its
own vaccine if approved it would be the
second latin american
vaccine the cuban shot is now in the
final stages of testing
mexico one of the countries worst
affected by the coronavirus pandemic
and dependent on imported vaccines in
short supply globally
to help reduce the country's future
dependency mexico is developing its
own vaccine named patria spanish for
homeland
the company spearheading the drive is
already eyeing clinical trials
the mexican government hopes the vaccine
can be approved for emergency use by the
end of the year
authorities say it has several
advantages
this is a vaccine that can be
administered as a nasal spray
and we've been laying the groundwork for
mass production
that will help keep costs low
and this in turn will make the vaccine
more accessible
to people in countries such as ours
which are not as wealthy
that's thanks in large part to drawing
on u.s technology
already used in other vaccines which the
mexican developer
says has proven safe and effective the
mexican government
has contributed to the funding
i think it's good i don't know when it
will come out
the problem here has been the lack of
support for research
so it will take a long time
mexico is a country that should be a
leader in the americas
and it should help supply other
countries in central america
mexico's president has condemned vaccine
hoarding by rich countries in the past
he says his nation will share its
vaccine with others
and i'm joined now by maria elena
alvarez puglia who we just saw
in that report she is the director of
mexico's national council of science and
technology
which is working on the development of
the patria
vaccine it's good to have you on the
program this vaccine
we understand it if it if it's approved
the approval could come by the end of
this year will that be too little too
late for the people of mexico
well no because one of the goals is to
recover the sufficiency the
self-sufficiency mexico used to have
in 99 for example to face
all the diseases that have to be
prevented with vaccines
and besides we still don't know how
this first vaccination will have to be
reinforced
and how mexico could help other
countries so it's not too late
never too late to become less dependent
on abroad for such strategic
aspects as a health so that's why
econosid
has been articulating capacities mexican
capacities both public
and private to recover this sufficiency
in the production of vaccines not only
against sarcophagus but for
other illnesses that are treated
with such vaccination
as a preventive names we know that the
vaccine that you're working on it's
designed to be administered as a nasal
spray what are the advantages of that
well uh the formulations are both nasal
and also intramuscular as other vaccines
so
both in animals at the preclinical
trials and the clinical trials
both types of formulations will be
tested and the combination of these
and of course even having one
of the administrations being nasal and
not intramuscular
makes it cheaper and also more practical
to be administered
at a very high rate so that's why we are
very interested in at least having one
of the administration being nasal
yeah i know that a lot of people around
the world not just in mexico would like
to have a nasal spray instead of
an injection with a needle i understand
that the clinical trials are just
beginning is it too early to talk about
what level of efficacy we're going to
have from this vaccine
yes it is too early we are just starting
the first
phase one trial clinical trial for
safety and the first
data on efficacy and immune response in
humans
but the preclinical data are very very
promising
that's good to hear what are the plans
for making this vaccine
accessible to other lower income
countries well if
the three clinical trial phases
are successful both in mexico and in
other countries
then we will be able to have a local i
mean latin american production we
already have
both the pilot
plant in mexico and also an industrial
plant being set up ready to scale up the
production of this vaccine
in case everything goes well which we
hope to
but we are ready also to transfer this
technology to other countries
in an open innovation platform which
we have agreed by the way this is a
technology that has been developed
developed both by mexican and american
scientists and also in spanish scientist
in collaborations
uh the the basis of it which is based on
the vector of newcastle
virus has been done for many years back
now
in collaboration between mexican public
and private
researchers and the american group so
mexico has a unique
uh formulation of this
vector for a vaccine against sarskoptos
ask you're doing very important work and
we certainly wish you much success we
hope that this vaccine
um works out exactly as you intend it to
do maria elena alvarez
julia director of mexico's national
council of science and technology
we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
thank you